the draft today is a little different
than usual today is the best free agent
pitches you can make to Tom Brady so
you're gonna have to be representing a
team and making the pitch to Tom Brady
that's the draft big cats got the trivia
question to determine who goes first lay
it on me
last season Tom Brady became the fourth
quarterback to play 20 seasons in the
league name any of the other three
quarterbacks to play for 20 plus years
George Blanda no how did you get that
wrong Brett Favre Vinny Testaverde man
George Blanda was a quarterback and a
killer all right I'll go first
ed you get to go first I got the best
pick this one's gonna be easy
I'm the Los Angeles chargers and I am
going to tell Tom Brady he needs to come
to LA he needs to come to Hollywood
Tinseltown where all the stars live you
can sell Gisele Bundchen hey Giselle you
want to live an ordinary life come to
Hollywood because if you are gel
bunching in Hollywood people won't care
all the stars live here and if you're
Tom Brady looking for your best chance
to get back to the playoffs or sorry he
was in the playoffs but get back to the
Super Bowl guess what and you're leaving
the Patriots that's what we're saying
the Chargers roster is ready to go
remember just last year they won 12
games this year Phillip Rivers up and
down play the missing piece is a
consistent quarterback they have Mike
Williams they have Keenan now and they
have hunter Henry Melvin Gordon will
rest on them we don't care they have the
offensive weapons to make Tom Brady look
around and say oh my gosh I'm playing
with these guys now and guess what they
got some defensive studs too so you
won't have to do it all on your own
you'll have an complimentary football
that is a plug and play situation and
you're the Chargers you get to be in LA
and you get to start a new franchise you
immediately get to be the guy in all of
LA all of Hollywood and we'll offer you
all the money for it because we're
trying to get people to buy tickets and
not be Rams fans so Tom Brady come on
over the Chargers we will make your life
beautiful
oh my friend you're in the right
division but you picked the wrong team
to start off with because the best pitch
from the AFC West comes from Jon Gruden
in the Las Vegas Raiders because Jon
Gruden knows quarterbacks he knows how
to coach quarterbacks he knows how to
get the most out of quarterbacks and
he's already on record as loving Tom
Brady Chris Sims explained earlier this
week that when Sims was playing for the
Buccaneers Gruden showed them film of
Brady walking off the field and was
smitten with how cool he looked he's
like George Costanza with Tony the male
bimbo as Jerry Seinfeld called him
they're gonna go rock climbing and
Gruden's bring in the sandwiches it's
gonna be great he can by Derek Carr's
house next door to Jon Gruden that car
will never live in because the Raiders
are gonna upgrade that Tom Brady silver
and black jersey once they get clearance
from the Stabler family to where number
12 even though the Raiders don't retire
jerseys they still out of courtesy would
make sure it's okay
you'd have t be 12 and silver and blacks
selling faster than any Jersey ever made
and look he can't play for the 49ers
unless they get in the mix the Raiders
were in Oakland at times when he was a
kid that's the next best thing to a
hometown team the Raiders first year in
Las Vegas huge money for Tom Brady new
stadium new vibe new everything and I
mean isn't that where like washed washed
up musicians go it's kind of the same
thing right watch the ball player go to
Las Vegas
Macario due due to a residency at
Allegiant Stadium so you are telling me
Mike if I'm Tom Brady in this situation
and you're pitching me and I have I
think he has three young children you
want me to move those young children to
the city of cinn no face what happens in
Vegas only happens in Vegas they've
chants the slogan your subject friendly
go okay only happens in Vegas alright
okay that's a coins in the fountain of
the Bellagio not a great pick but
whatever that's fine how about this one
Mike how about this pick
how about Tom Brady remember a little
play called
the catch oh yeah Chris Berman was there
and so were you
a young Tom Brady a six-year-old Tom
Brady in the stand
wearing a San Francisco 49ers jacket the
legend of Joe Montana the home of the
franchise that has the second most super
node
second most Super Bowl rings five in all
of the NFL come on home Tom Brady come
on home to the Bay Area we're in the
Super Bowl last year you know this team
is ready to go back there we will get
you a wide receiver we will run the ball
we will keep you protected we will play
defense and we'll be back in the Super
Bowl and guess what the greatest the
greatest ending for a Hall of Fame
career the greatest of all time career
is to finish where you started in San
Francisco at Candlestick will reopen
Candlestick for you I don't care
Tom Brady come on home win a title for
the San Francisco 49ers the legacy the
colors the the you know the 80s just
everything the mystique do it you will
be a hero forever in two regions now and
we welcome you with open arms also Jimmy
Garoppolo sorry buddy you're gone yeah
you know I listen I don't say this
lightly that was a horrible pick by you
know it wasn't you don't you don't need
to pitch Tom Brady I'm playing for the
49ers right all they have to say all
they have you don't have to do it to do
it to do is pick up his phone and see it
four one five number and he's gonna
answer and say are you ready for me I'm
coming I'm coming you don't need to
pitch it you don't need to make a pitch
the job pitches itself so you just
proved my point for me that's the best
pitch I don't but he doesn't want him
that's not the name of the draft the
draft is pitches I just gave you the
best pitch you just admitted I gave you
the best pitch oh my god don't weak it's
so easy to mop the floor with you I dug
my third pick which is unbelieving
listen you can say same thing about the
Chiefs right we've got Andy Reid we've
got a great offense we've got Tyree kill
we've got Sammy Watkins but we got
Patrick mahomes they don't want him oh
the horse if the Chiefs wanted him he'd
want the Chiefs if the 49ers wanted me
once the 49ers they don't want him
incorrect the 49ers at G we know John
Lynch called for Tom Brady
we know that there's some doubts about
Jimmy Garoppolo to say they absolutely
don't want them put comparing it to the
Chiefs makes you look even dumber than
you already looked another point for me
stats put it up put it in parentheses
Mike Florio dummy after my pick with the
49ers the next one for me and I would do
it in my Jerry Jones voice but my Jerry
Jones voice needs a lot of work I am
fascinated by the possibility of Jerry
Jones saying to dak Prescott look we've
tried to sign you to a long term
contract we have offered you umpteen
different structures and figures and you
continue to say no so I want to win a
Super Bowl and I want to do it with Tom
Brady and Tom we can give you an
offensive line unlike any you've ever
had a running back unlike any you've
ever had receivers far better than this
revolving door of mediocrity that you're
dealing with in New England we got a new
coach who's trying to prove himself
again Mike McCarthy and he's won a Super
Bowl and we will pay you a ton of money
and you will be the quarterback of
America's Team you will become America's
quarterback we will talk to Roger
Staubach about getting you number 12 he
will say it's okay and we will go and we
will get it done in the worst division
in football see you go to the AFC West
you got to deal with Patrick mahomes you
got to play in Denver where Tom Brady
has a losing record you go to the NFC
West you got to deal with the Rams and
the Seahawks and the Cardinals who are
on the upswing you go to the NFC East
you got a bunch of crap teams you're
gonna be just like Tom Brady with the
Patriots in the AFC East we run
roughshod over the division get the
number one seed force the road to the
Super Bowl to come through AT&T Stadium
and the Cowboys get to the Super Bowl
and Tom gets number seven and he walks
off into the sunset and Jerry Jones can
say mission accomplished I finally have
a Super Bowl win with a team that I
built Cowboys for Tom Bakk that was the
49ers picked just way worse everything
you just said was what I said for the
49ers just way worse all right yeah and
it's true okay here's my third pick I
think it's more likely he plays for the
Cowboys in the 49ers okay so here's my
third pick and this is why I am me and
you are you Mike and why I win and you
lose constantly now I'm going to speak
about something that might get
in trouble here but that's only because
I respect the people at NBC and the job
that they do on football night of
America and Sunday night we go so I'm
going not gonna talk about NBC I'm not
gonna talk about Chris Collinsworth I am
Jimmy potaro I'm walking into Tom
Brady's lair into his office I'm saying
Tom Brady a wise man once said it's
better to burn out than to fade away
okay you don't want to be 44 year old
Tom Brady throwing interceptions looking
old having people remember you in in in
a uniform that is not the New England
Patriots do you know what I have for you
I have 15 million dollars I will give
you 15 million dollars to be the voice
of Monday Night Football
you will stay relevant you everyone will
love you look at what Tony Romo did you
were 10 times the quarterback Tony Romo
was you know more football than Tony
Romo ever even like looked at you can be
great at this job we will put you in a
position to win everyone will love you
and guess what you can do every single
week you could talk about the t b12
method to millions and millions of
people on Monday Night Football oh and
let me throw in this too
you ever heard of a little thing called
American Idol well guess what does
Gisele want to host it now she's the
host of it boom that's the greatest
thing ever
no more concussions no more injuries
your kids can live in the same place you
don't have to move the family we have
just given you the greatest day the
greatest thing of your life you have to
work one day a week and you are a legend
forever you go into the Hall of Fame six
rings greatest of all time and you also
go into the Hall of Fame being a great
broadcaster and everyone loves you your
second act has started today
thank you signed that's a great pic we
what do you do is Seacrest he just gave
his job away I don't care
we'll figure that out later look that's
a horrible pitch because he's gonna play
football he's made it clear he said it
in the Hulu commercial I'm not in there
not if I walked in that door I could
probably could sell it sell me that
million he don't care about 15 million
he doesn't care about that he 15 later
no doing next year he can do it after 15
million peanuts for a hike Mike listen
he does care about 15 million because 15
million would be such an insane amount
of money to pay a
broadcasters never broadcast before Tom
Brady has never has he ever been the
highest-paid quarterback in the NFL I
don't think he has well guess what will
make you the highest-paid broadcaster in
the history of broadcasting okay my last
pick is simple and it goes like this
Tom you can't pick the free agency I'm
Bill Belichick and the rest of them
aren't and do you want to win do you not
want to win and look I think at the end
of the day as fascinated as I am by the
possibility of Tom Brady going to
another team and and yet last year was
rough but he's got Bill Belichick
he's got Josh McDaniels nick Kesari Oh
has stayed put I don't think at the end
of the day he's gonna want to uproot his
career after 20 years with one
organization and start from scratch and
I just think all this is is driven by
vanity attention and I think if the if
the Patriots just press the right
buttons
with Tom Brady and offer him enough
money I think that he stays put and I
think that the fact that Bill Belichick
is Bill Belichick is enough to make it
happen we got to take a break
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports